banide et certaines exploitations
traditionnelles les insectes sont au
contraire convoité en pas ma culture
hier après-midi la filière des
maraîchers bio de la région a formé ses
producteurs à reconnaître ceux qui
peuvent être utiles reportage abus ayant
touraine de nathanaël le maire et yves
le bois donc on distribue les petits des
petits tubes à chaque participante pour
prélever les insectes vous allez voir
dans la dans la parcelle la chasse aux
insectes dans des champs en permaculture
entre dans une formation régionale à
destination des maraîchers bio au jardin
de la butte à merveille en touraine
fabien jobard tout travail sa terre en
production bio et même plus le travail
de la terre s'inscrit dans un
environnement plus vaste au delà de la
production biologique pour moi une
biodiversité maximum qu'elle soit de
plantes d'insectes de karaboue haute va
forcément participé à un équilibre et
l'objectif c'est voilà d'aller vers un
système qui est le plus équilibré
possible le plus diversifié
donc forcément il ya un intérêt vers les
insectes accompagnés par des
associations naturalistes ce maraîcher
offre un exemple d'exploitation en
permaculture tout s'équilibre sans
apport extérieur une conduite
d'exploitation qui offre des clés de
compréhension pour tous les maraîchers
l'idée c'est qu'ils soient bien
conscients de la de la faune qui est
présente dans leurs parcelles de comment
essayer d'augmenter cette biodiversité
ce qu'on sait que sur un écosystème à
l'école ce qui a qui va présenter une
une faune extrêmement diverse et riche
on aura des problématiques sanitaires
qui sont nettement nettement moins
problématique quoi ici les insectes
deviennent des auxiliaires de culture et
bien connaître toutes ces petites bêtes
s'avère très utile quand on cultive en
bio est intéressant d'entendre des
spécialistes
des anciens et qu'ils nous expliquent et
voilà avant il y avait beaucoup plus de
diversité maintenant et qui sont nos
fermes on retrouve tout doucement du
coup la diversité qu'on a perdu qu'on a
perdu en grandes cultures donc c'est
intéressant de se dire que finalement
même si on n'y arrive pas on quelque
chose de bien comme quoi c'est créer un
équilibre sans aussi le contrôle et
pourrait dire laventure de la
permaculture devient une éthique de vie
pour le maraîcher pour les consommateurs
et pour les citoyens en recherche d'un
autre rapport avec la nature